the richest University in the world
helping grad students apply for food
stamps Harvard which sits on a whopping
53 billion dollar endowment putting on
an event to help its graduate students
apply for food assistance a flower
promoting and saying quote fuel your
body and stock your pantry
did you know that grad students may
qualify to receive assistance paying for
food and groceries we as Harvard for
comments but didn't hear back
exclamation point what's your thoughts I
love this so much I live for the moment
where you see like a grad student on the
side of the road like outside of
Cambridge with a sign that says we'll
apply gender ideology through a
deconstructive lens for food
because that's what they do by the way I
went to college it's hard to believe but
no matter how broke you are there's
always Top Ramen like I had Top Ramen
three times a day and then when I
finally got a microwave the hot dogs the
microwave hot dogs you can live
literally off three dollars a day and I
know that because I did I think it's
hilarious that somebody can afford to go
to uh to Harvard but can't afford a ham
sandwich that's a sign that you're
making terrible choices in your life you
know what maybe concentrate on making
some money instead of Throwing It All
Away to people who are going to destroy
the world
talk
about the rising costs of Education we
as we talked in the context of retiring
student debt we said one of the things
that Congress should do is hold hearings
on why these tuitions keep going up it
seems weird that tuitions are so high
and they they can't at least feed the
kids well and also you have an endowment
that that's that Harvard is that for us
to attack their endowment that so they
have this huge amount of money just
sitting in a pot and they don't pay
taxes on it but they want their students
to be more reliant on government which
you pay for
this is insanity and everybody should be
mad about it Charles Payne was on
Newsroom this morning he had another
good point in the supplemental that
President Biden either just got or just
asked for they asked for three billion
dollars to address homelessness okay all
right maybe we could all agree that that
needs to be done they asked for 39
billion dollars to pay for a certain
amount of
student loans and student loans were
those are costs that they knew were
coming it's not like oh my gosh I I
don't know I all of a sudden I have the
600 payment I don't know where it came
from they know because that's where they
got it from
um but homeless people don't vote
these young people that want these
student loan forgiveness they do I think
you're right Charlie you got an opinion
on this well I agree with uh Greg I do
think that this is just sort of it's
like a boot camp for uh a gender studies
graduate yes uh you know they're turning
out all these social justice Warriors
turns out that they can't get a job but
I don't understand why they don't turn
their social justice warriors on Harvard
itself and of course the federal
government because uh you know the thing
that almost never gets talked about
certainly not when uh Biden is talking
about it is the fact that the degree to
which the federal government with
student loans and the degree to which
they are what are inflating all of these
tuitions and allowing Harvard to have a
53 billion dollar endowment that as Dana
points out is not taxed
um it's uh you know that that's they're
the they're the biggest problem in in
this uh in this whole economic cycle
that's going in the wrong direction be
curious to see some of these grad
students how many of them have loans uh
to go to school I know In fairness to
Harbor I want the pen these schools are
using some of their endowment to help
income students be able to afford an
education but this doesn't this just
doesn't jive right it doesn't sit right
it doesn't sit right and they think that
a 53 billion dollar endowment I'm not
defending them by the way I ate macaroni
and cheese
but twice as much cheese yeah I'd save
the cheese but anyway so this is a push
to socialism now think about it
two-thirds of the taxpayers in this
country are not college educated so what
the Harvard is doing is they're pushing
their own students to get food stamps
the two-thirds of the taxpayers who
never went to college are paying for for
very little a 150th of their endowment
of 53 billion dollars they could raise a
stipend of these grad students and allow
them to be able to eat and take the
burden off the taxpayer but that's not
what Harvard's about Harvard is about
the idea of this liberal ideology and
push these people to learn to rely on
the government and save as much money as
they can I think it's I think it's a
tragedy why did you why did you poke fun
at me I was agreeing with you
I don't even know that I love you Harold
but sometimes love hurts I eat pizza and
subs and Philly cheesesteaks
exactly is that a college it was when I
was there coming up talk about getting
blindsided
the NFL star behind the hit movie
accusing the family who took him in of
make took him in of making millions and
not telling the truth about it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else